Pope Francis says the Roman Catholic
Church should fight an all-out battle
against sex abuse he addressed nearly
200 bishops and senior leaders at the
end of a four-day meeting yesterday the
Vatican said it would publish a
guidebook for bishops that will help
them understand their duties and tasks
on abuse Nicky batiste is in Rome with
some disappointed reaction to this
summit Nicky good morning Nora good
morning we spoke with three clergy abuse
survivors the moments after they watched
Pope Francis address a crowd Sunday
right below me and safe Peter's Square
we have followed their fight for justice
since last year all the way from the
u.s. to here in Rome today they want to
know why the Catholic Church has still
not laid out concrete steps to stop
child sex abuse how are you feeling
after hearing the Pope speech I don't
think our children are any safer now
than four days ago by what I heard
what's one word you would use to
describe how this summit went short fall
disappointing start what would you say
to survivors and victims listening who
might be disappointed by this summit
don't give up it's a long journey stay
united and we will get this done to
protect all children of the world so
much of the discussion about what this
summit would be was about holding
accountable the bishops who covered up
sexual abuse or were abusers themselves
do you think now that the summit's and
bishops will be are being held more
accountable I don't
III would like to say that it's a start
but unless he starts removing bishops
who egregiously covered up these crimes
he's not leading by example he promised
concrete steps have you heard that now
that it's ended I have another plan that
was a recognition of what we already
knew it seems like the church finally
gets it now that you do understand that
this is happening and you said that your
bishops are compal where's the next step
where is the action plan is there any
positive and the fact
or here that the church is having a
conversation about child sex abuse that
it hasn't in the past it has started a
conversation that should have been
started a long time ago I would say
Frances this this is the moment this is
your time
clean up your church get rid of the
pedophiles do it and do it now
Cardinal Daniel DiNardo the president of
the US Conference of Catholic Bishops
acknowledges that specific action still
needs to be determined u.s. bishops will
gather in June at an annual meeting
where they will consider proposals on
how to move forward and deal with the
abuse Noora Noora less rhetoric more
action Niki thank you